okay so as as I grab here my Center
drops right you guys see that so you
have to pull this at the front
chaki but your Center drop so you can
hit okay you check boom and then your
first strike is going to be with the
shoulder on the ground
P
here so it's two boom you see how I'm
doing that as opposed to I'm just going
to hug him
so hit and he starts moving and what now
that he starts moving he's
easy to keep
moving
okay try it
again
I'm doing my opening and I take the two
on one okay and it's not going to be
like sumos where I come out here and
then I take that
corner the first thing I'm going to do
is take his arm completely behind him do
you see it's way back
here that's where I trade finish my
entry and the
throw so you get the idea you just
standing a
horse you want this back
here key Sim up here okay this one goes
back
here B the
throw you
hit so boom two on one just walk it
behind him
you see he's going to he's going to want
to turn you
see so you body walk it you got to keep
that hip close to him
okay and you got to keep weight on that
leg so it's weight heavy weight heavy
weight is heavy okay up through his face
boom okay try it
again
[Music]
from two on one you're taking him into
that back
kazushi pattern okay but at this time
I'm going to find the front inward Kushi
so the front inward would be like he's
going to do a forward
roll can you come back and do the
forward
roll
okay and it's on the
elbow it's very common that he tries to
overpower me and he pulls in so I'm
going to follow it in and it's right
here okay grab on to your own wrist you
can grab on to your hand it doesn't
really matter it's right here that I
want okay and I just s
tou so again boom two on one he pulls
boom
okay just go with it and drop the elbow
into the front inward
position